this shouldn't want a flak jacket if I
was gonna cover this one okay so I have
talked about Doctor Who series 11 in a
variety of ways up to this point I have
done episode by episode reviews I did a
general overview of the series as a
whole ones the last episode had aired
and under extreme duress I even talked
about the ratings that one time just to
stop all you people from asking which in
hindsight was probably a bad precedent
to set crap also I had initially planned
to get fancier with the editing on this
video you know include clips things like
that but see how I'm still battling with
the BBC over the last video I tried to
do that on I am gonna hold off on that
when it comes to Doctor Who for the time
being
anyways because my overview review of
series 11 was unscripted I did my usual
thing you know just kind of touching on
everything not really diving much into
the specifics I also was in that video
pointing out both the positives and the
negatives because I felt there was
plenty of both to talk about I still
feel that way for the record but I ended
up getting a certain amount of deja vu
between series 11 and my feelings on
Star Wars the last Jedi which is to say
I see a lot of problems with the thing
but they're not the problems that other
people seem to be talking about or at
least they aren't the ones that are
being shouted about the loudest so what
this is gonna be is mostly just me
laying out precisely what I think the
problems with series 11 actually world
and also to clear up some
things that I think very much were not
the problems so series 11 while not
without merit and even a few standout
episodes is one of the most uneven
series that new who has given us I put
it in kind of a cluster of iffy series
along with the likes of series is to
seven and eight and while all four of
these do share the quality of being a
mixed bag with a minority of high points
the specific failings of series 11 they
well they feel a bit different from the
others
the first and foremost difference being
that I can look at series two seven and
eight and say that the show was trying
something substantively
different in each instance series two
brought a different doctor companion
dynamic you know without actually
swapping the companion for somebody new
series seven it tried for a mid series
split and no two parters series eight
removed to the split kept the no two
parters and went with a less immediately
likeable doctor which was also new for
this show or at least the revival series
eleven okay well there's the three
companion thing but um on that it felt
like the series was taking things away
rather than adding anything new
when I say it feels like things were
just being taken away I I'm gonna give
some examples of what I'm talking about
here because otherwise it just sounds
like I'm making stuff up series 11 tried
again for the no two-parter format
despite the fact that the two series
that did that previously were some of
the weaker ones to date but they decide
to do it anyway it ditched the mystery
box overarching narrative in fact it
didn't really have an overarching
narrative at all it featured no
returning villains because I'm talking
about the series proper here I'm not
counting the New Year special and most
prominently it's shaved down the episode
count now there's nothing inherently
wrong with any of these changes heck I
said before I'm beyond sick of the
mystery box style series arcs but as a
general rule I think if you're gonna
remove that much it's probably a good
idea to replace it with something and
series 11 doesn't really feel like it
did that I think the fewer episodes
exemplifies what I'm saying here
probably the cleanest I I remember when
that kind of now's there was a very
mixed reaction to that initial amount
announcement of 10 episodes per series
as opposed to the 12 that Capaldi had
gotten per series or the 13 episodes per
series that were granted to Smith tenant
and Eccleston now when that was
initially announced some people just
flat-out saw it as bad omen others
thought it could be a good thing but
most folks at least from where I sat
seemed to agree that it would be an
acceptable trade if it meant each
episode was stronger as a result and
that's the thing this series wasn't
different enough from what doctor who
was already doing that the loss of two
episodes feels like it was an aid of
anything it just feels like less it also
puts more pressure on each episode I've
actually talked about this before I even
dedicated a video on it a while back
that one was in the context of female
superheroes you know linked
they're all that but the fewer instances
there are of something the more pressure
that is put on each of those instances
if you only give us ten episodes it
becomes more important than ever that
most of them be strong pieces of work
and while I personally only found two
episodes of series 11 to be what I would
consider to be flat-out bad it had five
that were little more than some form of
just okay now for comparison I'm
personally of the opinion that series
eight also had five bland episodes but
in the case of series eleven that same
number of myth entries ends up being
literally half the series when you give
us less each failure carries more weight
this was gonna be a highly scrutinized
series no matter what but the fewer
episodes only exacerbated the whole
thing I remember before the series
started airing seeing some people sort
of referencing Marvel Netflix shows in
regards to you know the potential
benefits of shaving off episodes because
even the best of those shows were two to
five episodes longer than they needed to
be and one of those have been better
with fewer episodes well yeah I've said
as much myself but the difference is
that those Marvel Netflix shows were
largely serialized stories so the extra
episodes just ended up being padded
filler that delayed the overarching plot
series eleven didn't do an overarching
plot so nothing gets inherently
tightened from shortening it I don't
know if a more serialized story you know
something along the lines of Chibnall
zone broadchurch would have actually
worked maybe maybe not but at least it
would have been a choice that would make
the loss of episodes more meaningful
than it was you know it would have added
something instead of just taking things
away also like I should be clear that I
my suspicion is
the episode count was the BBC's call
rather than ship nose own personal
preference but knowing that if that call
was made above his head it would have
happened you know well ahead of the
writing and he just didn't take
advantage of what that meant he didn't
do anything with it
one of the few things that was tangibly
changes that we've got more companions
in the TARDIS than has ever happened
before in new whoo and yet I don't think
that there's anyone who didn't feel this
was a detriment to the series as a whole
it's the one common complaint that I
hear that I absolutely share like if
this many companions was ever gonna work
it needed to happen in a series that was
not also introducing us to a whole new
doctor even the times before we're new
did you know two companions like Rory
and Amy bill and nardole it was with a
doctor we already knew so with four new
characters because introducing a new
doctor is pretty much like introducing a
whole new character there just isn't
enough time to give them all something
to do and a chance to bond with the
audience or even each other especially
with fewer episodes to do it in rather
than get to know the new doctor and one
companion really well like has always
been the case before in new who instead
we got to know a new doctor and three
other people very superficially I've
mentioned before that yaz is easily the
most superfluous of the bunch not that
she's actually a bad character or as
poorly performed but she's almost never
given anything to do even the one
episode that centers the most on her
which is demons of the Punjab is way
more about her ancestors than it is
about her so she was really just the
narrative device that got us there once
the setups done
she's just passively passively observing
you know just like the rest of us now
it's an admittedly great story that she
gets to see unfold but shouldn't do much
and even if the show chuck to yaz and
kept the stronger pairing of graham and
ryan whose relationship has an actual
arc it still would have been a problem
because the relationship we should be
getting invested in is the one that the
company
have with the doctor and I honestly
couldn't tell you why any of these three
are traveling with her I can look back
to earlier series and I can tell you not
only why each of the previous companions
chose to go with the doctor but I can
also tell you why the doctor wanted them
to join I honestly couldn't tell you why
the doctor gloms onto these three aside
from the fact that they just happened to
be the first folks she ran into and I
don't know why the companions go with
her after that first accidental
adventure you know grandma Narayan okay
I'm a little maybe because being away
from home means they don't have to deal
as head-on with grace being dead but
that's not laid out properly or paid off
properly either and it still leaves yaza
the also-ran regardless relatedly it
really does bother me that I didn't
click with Joanie Whitaker's doctor
until the literal very end of the series
now I pointed out before that this isn't
the first time that has taken me a while
to get on board with a doctor I didn't
really properly gel with Capaldi until
his second series and I still haven't
had my aha moment with Davison I'm
starting to doubt I ever will but in
those cases I can still point to just
not connecting with the doctor that I'm
given which sucks what happens with the
thirteenth doctor but Jodie what
occurred the disconnect wasn't that I
didn't connect with who the doctor was
it was because I just flat-out didn't
know who this doctor was at all by the
time the series ended I felt like I
finally had a proper sense of her but if
the show hadn't cut episodes while
simultaneously bloating the cast there
would have been enough space for her to
just flat-out beep present
it's enough for me to get what I was
even being given and once I understood I
actually quite liked it but it shouldn't
have taken that long
I'm of the opinion that the biggest
overriding problem was series 11 is that
the stories rarely feel like they're in
service of anything greater than
themselves because even a standalone
Doctor Who's story should be bringing
something to the table if they want it
to be more than just fluff there's
nothing wrong with fluff that can work
but you can't have a series of nothing
but fluff you know something it could be
a new scenario for the doctor a strain
on the doctor companion dynamic a hint
at some side of a character that we
haven't seen before etc etc blink wasn't
only a great standalone story it gave us
a whole new perspective on how these
kinds of events look and feel for people
who aren't the doctor and the companion
and yes I know technically lava monsters
did at first but lava monsters did it
badly Heaven Sent wasn't just a great
standalone story it perfectly
encapsulated the doctors tenacity and
the fake of insurmountable odds it made
that the true focus to a degree that
hadn't happened before
Dalek isn't just a great standalone
story it shows a vicious streak that the
doctor have been trying to hide heck an
episode doesn't even have to be good to
still contribute something to think la
is a middling episode I have a little
affection for it but it's not great but
through an observation by Queen Victoria
it plants the notion of the dr. Andros
as being far too flippant and cavalier
with the forces that they toy with which
is something that will pay off by the
end of series two series 11 episodes
don't feel like they're in aid of
anything they just happen and then
they're gone they're popcorn even the
good ones don't seem to have much
lasting impact I genuinely love it takes
you away seriously I think it's great
but all it really does for the
characters is reestablished Graham's
feelings of loss over you know grace
without offering any new insight into
them if it was intended to just fuel his
revenge goal in the next episode it
doesn't work because it doesn't build
those
emotions any more than any previous
episode had done Oh does is remind us
that this is a thing there's an overall
lack of ambition about just the entire
enterprise it doesn't feel like a bold
new direction so much as an attempt to
just meet expectations I honestly feel
like it takes you away was the only
episode that legitimately swung for the
fences I do like some of the other
episodes
KaBlam demons of the punjab as far as
i'm concerned they're top-notch but even
those felt like they weren't trying to
do more than just be good enough for as
bold as the surface level changes to the
show were the actual episodes are
incredibly safe
now you may have noticed something that
haven't brought up yet and that's the
whole idea of politics somehow ruining
the show because I don't think they did
politics or agendas are not the problem
with these episodes well okay a raccoons
in the UK was made all the worse by the
horrendously on-the-nose character that
poor chris noth had to play but even
that wasn't really ruined by the
politics because if you remove that
character that awful awful character
which is actually really easy to do
because he isn't necessary to the story
at all the episode is still not any good
his presence doesn't help but the
episode stunk already he didn't ruin it
so much as just happen to also be there
and that's kind of my point I can see a
lot of problems with series 11 but I
don't see any of them being caused by
the fact that the doctor is now a woman
or the companions are now more diverse
series 11 has serious problems and the
doctor is now a woman but that's a
correlation that's not causation seeing
people get hung up on those very visible
changes reminded me of the lead-up to
the first season of iron fist there was
a conversation that happened within the
fandom about whether or not the
character of Danny Rand aka the iron
fist should have been reinvented revisit
the actual debate but just know that it
was something that was in the
conversation you know but before the
thing premiered but when the first
season of iron fist came out and it was
awful I actually said in my review
there's so much wrong with this show
I would really hate to think that if
they
cast a chinese-american actor that there
would have been a certain stripe of fan
who would have come in and said see this
is what happens where you change the
race of a character when the problems
with this show have nothing to do with
that and even if they had done that
wouldn't have been that would've been
the problem either so at this point I'm
glad they didn't given how much the
thing sucks and I'm glad people don't
have that to scapegoat and that's
basically how I see series 11 when it
comes to these arguments the show did so
little where the gender actually
affected the narrative honestly you
could make the 13th doctor a man only
have to switch a few lines of dialogue
and basically leave everything I was the
same the gender didn't substantively
impact the show and keeping the doctor a
man still would leave all the exact same
problems I'm talking about
even though witch finders the episode
that in theory should have been most
impacted by the gender change wouldn't
have to be altered much to still work
with the doctor as a man men got tried
for witchcraft too and the show didn't
actually do much to play into her gender
under the circumstances of that story
the true problems of series 11 are two
fundamental to have been worsened caused
or even affected by what has so far
proven to be a pretty superficial change
to the doctor I have absolutely no doubt
that somewhere along the line somebody
is going to or possibly already has
argue that the gender swap and the caste
diversity aka the SJW agenda stuff
simply being present at all was still
somehow the cause of the bad writing
maybe they'll say that the writers
thought that they could put in less
effort and just coast on progressive
goodwill which is unprovable if you
weren't in the writers room so you might
as well claim that the writing was bad
because everybody got depressed from
being served the same lunch every day
may
these theoretical commenters will say
that there was too much effort put on
these changes and not enough on the
stories except that the decision to do
these casting changes didn't require any
continual effort from Chibnall or the
writers it's just the initial casting so
how exactly does making a casting
decision that gets announced well ahead
of the writing cause there to be less
effort put into the scripts this
theoretical commenter is probably also
liable to point out that the writing
staff was prioritized as being diverse
which is not theory that's actually true
Chibnall himself did flatly say that
diversity in the writers room was a
consideration when assembling the
writing team and this person might say
that most of these writers had little
background in sci-fi which okay actually
there is at least a little meat on that
bone the writing staff may well have
been in over their heads and a lack of
genre experience could have contributed
to that and if more of a priority was
given to diversity rather than
experience and the relevance on row
which isn't exactly what Chip Nell said
but it wouldn't be a massive or
altogether unfair presumption to assume
that then maybe there's something to
this the thing is I actually feel that
this argument falls apart when we look
at the actual results you know the
episodes themselves and who wrote what
because the guy at the head of the whole
thing the middle-aged white guy who has
been writing science fiction and Doctor
Who specifically for years doesn't have
that excuse and yet his scripts are
consistently some of the weakest in the
series the best episodes of series 11
were all written by people not named
Chris Chibnall so while this whole
concern might have had some validity as
a you know possible problem ahead of the
release of the series it just doesn't
really square with what we've got as to
the diverse companions I've already
talked about the fact that too many of
them is a problem
but that is nothing to do with diversity
that's just too many but not only do I
feel that the racial diversity among the
three companions is not a cause of any
additional problems I feel like it's
worth pointing out that two of the most
praised episodes those being Rosa and
demons of the Punjab were really the
only ones that actually built stories
around the racial aspects and despite my
own complicated feelings about Rosa a
clearly connected with many people and
demons of the Punjab is terrific so the
few times that the show actually did
lean into one of the only new elements
that was brought in ie
the race of the Companions the results
were actually stronger and better
received than the episodes where these
characters could have been swapped out
for white men with no story impact funny
that
so ultimately if I were to sum it all up
the problem here is a lack of purpose
and ambition say what you will about
Moffitt I've said plenty
Oh hume off it but the man went big
which meant he succeeded big and he
failed big Davies I would argue was more
even-keeled than Moffitt but his base
level was still reliably fun and
energetic entertainment with a bit of
emotional drama he still brought a
pretty distinct flavor to the
proceedings series 11 makes chip don't
feel like well makes him feel like a
company man don't rock the boat meet
expectations don't overshoot keep it
simple because for as much as people
made a huge deal about the casting
there's nothing bold or different or
even particularly self-assured about
series 11 outside of that casting it
feels very much like a show that's just
trying to get by and is afraid to be big
or bold it feels like middle-of-the-road
entertainment that doesn't want to be
much more than that in this this is the
last thing Doctor Who should be doing
now I've said before that I don't think
this means chip mill should actually be
booted from his Shore on her position
and despite everything I just said in
this video I actually still stand by
that because I want to see how he'll
change when tackling his next series
what lessons will he learn what new
ideas will he bring on board
how will he evolve if when we finally
get series 12 the answer ends up being
well he didn't evolve at all and we get
something eerily similar to series 11
that is what I'm gonna get genuinely
worried and might even start hoping for
a behind the scenes you know change in
management kind of deal because I
believe Doctor Who is strong enough to
survive a rough series I mean it's done
it before heck you know with my own
opinions on which series aren't that
great
the fact that it includes Series seven
and eight it's arguably recovered from
two lousy Series in a row but even there
there were notable changes from one
series to the other even outside the
regeneration and the new doctor when it
came to series 8 Moffat didn't just kick
back and do the same thing he did in
series 7 it still didn't quite work in
my opinion but at least it didn't just
repeat the same mistakes it made new
mistakes which at least shows effort it
shows growth or at the very least
attempts at it and that is what I need
to see from chip mill and his writing
team evidence of effort I'll note that
as of time of recording we don't know
who the other writers on series 12 are
gonna be besides II D Heim who wrote it
takes you away and is therefore in my
estimation a good person to keep on cuz
as I said that felt like the only truly
ambitious episode but whether the other
writers are new or diverse or are
veterans of earlier series I just need
to see more effort on display from the
scripting side of things because I feel
like the cast and the directors because
I haven't mentioned this but the show
looked damn good it should be said I
feel like the cast and the directors are
trying to pull the weight of a
frustratingly high percentage of limp
scripts and they can't be the only ones
trying
if series 12 isn't much better than
series 11 I just hope that whatever
changes might happen because of that are
all behind the scenes and they aren't
laid at the feet of the diverse cast who
was trying to do their best with
frequently mediocre material if you want
to blame anybody
you know what the writers are the ones
that probably deserve most of the blame
for the problems of series 11 pretty
much all the problems are writing
problems I get that maybe not everybody
clicked when these companions are
clicked with this doctor but I don't
think there is inherently something
wrong with the performances doesn't mean
you have to like them but I don't think
that those are the
the writings the problem and it's not
the writing of the diverse writing team
that's the problem it's chip no that's
the problem right now he didn't he
didn't have a plan I mean we heard this
thing that he had a five-year plan
there's no evidence of a plan behind
series eleven it just kind of happens so
if his five-year plan was to just be
inoffensive that's not good enough
and it wouldn't be good enough for Jodi
Whitaker's doctor it wouldn't have been
good enough for Capaldi Smith Tennant
Eccleston or any of the classic doctors
when all you aim for is to be good
enough
it is not good enough so step it up
Chris please those are my thoughts on
what the problems with series 11
actually were as well as some of what
they very much were not those are my
thoughts on it I am gonna have a lot of
fun moderating the comments section on
this one aren't I well we'll see
whatever your thoughts on what I've said
keep them respectful you can disagree
with me without being a jerk about it
and you can also disagree with other
commenters without being a jerk that's
the only rule don't be a jerk if you can
abide by it drop whatever you think down
in the comments and let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff to do buttons links
yeah patreon I've got my Amazon wish
list down there cuz my birthday this
month also p.o box if you want to send
me something that's not just off the
wish list so check that stuff out hey
you know it'd be thoughtful it'd be nice
but also you don't have to because at
the end of the day you're the council
and I'm just running the meetings so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]